[Musica]
salve sono radio valenti nessuno romeno
non pratico kung fu e anzi questo è un
vestito è un un abito tipico della
romania si chiama io diciamo è stato
cucito dalla nonna di mia nonna per il
suo futuro sposo a più di 100 anni e ho
deciso di indossarlo per esprimervi
meglio prima che con le parole
il mio orgoglio di essere rumeno se sono
qui oggi è perché un giorno mentre stavo
rientrando da torino con il mio
professore ci siamo trovati a parlare
diciamo del mio paese rientravamo dal
salone del libro
ad un certo punto ho parlato di un
autore mihai eminescu il prof
non lo conosceva però è stato subito
incuriosito perché gli avevo detto che
aveva scritto il poema d'amore più lungo
del mondo
passiamo molto tempo a leggere ea
tradurre lucio farul leggere e tradurre
ovviamente non lo finimmo tutto perché
lunghissimo e ne io ne il prof
abbiamo molta pazienza diciamo è
diventata una scoperta per me ma è stata
anche un'esperienza bellissima perché
avevo capito che non era l'unico autore
di di cui poter parlare e far scoprire
la romania è così
un pomeriggio mi sono messo a studiare
per più di quattro ore e ricercare di
capire tutti gli autori e tutti i grandi
uomini della romania
inoltre usando i social network mi sono
messo in contatto con docenti del mio
paese che mi hanno appunto segnalato i
casi degli autori più grandi rumeno come
me e stefan c'è il mare re della
moldavia nel quindicesimo secolo
combatte 36 battaglie ne vinse 34 dopo
ogni vittoria faceva costruire un
monastero
perciò la moldavia né bellissima il
rumeno come me
henry quando l'ingegnere aeronautico
ideò il primo aereo senza elica costruì
il primo cannone per gli aerei senza
rinculo e ideò un pannello solare per la
desalinizzazione dell'acqua marina
rumeno come me e nicolae paola sco
grandissimo scienziato fu il primo a
scoprire il rimedio per i diabetici la
panchina però per mancanza di fondi non
riuscì a portare al termine la ricerca
e così due canadesi lo fecero prima di
lui quel rimedio fu poi chiamato
insulina
c'è un oggetto che è entrato nella vita
di noi tutti e chissà forse tra poco ne
uscirà penna portatile senza fine che si
ricarica da sola con inchiostro lei
definì il suo ideatore
era un miracolo al tempo la prima penna
stilografica fu brevettata da un 28enne
rumeno ci sono persone che chissà come e
chissà perché riescono ad essere primo
in tutto lui fu primo a viaggiare con un
treno
lui fu il primo a portare un giornale in
romania e inoltre il cambio alla scuola
e la politica romeno come me e petrachi
poi naro la conoscete vero le non ha
bisogno di presentazioni
sapete quanto ci hanno messo a
costruirla 2 anni e 4 mesi
dietro questo grande record c'è un
ingegnere rumeno al signor eiffel sono
tributati tutti gli onori ma il vero
miracolo lo ha fatto questo ingegnere
40enne rumeno come me e jorge fun cool
esco la world record academy l'ha
riconosciuto come il poema d'amore più
lungo del mondo 99 strofe e lucio for
all
l'opera più più nota di mihai eminescu
rumeno come me
narra di catalina una ragazza che guarda
in a stella lucio for all e se ne
innamora
la stella si innamora anche lei e le
chiede di diventare immortale per amarsi
per sempre ma lei rifiuta e dice che è
lui che deve scendere sulla terra e
diventare mortale
allora il duo immortale cosa fa decide
di morire per amore e va dal dio padre
per essere esaudito
ma intanto accade qualcosa caterina fa
innamorare catelyn non una stella ma un
umile servitore e lei finisce per
innamorarsi anche lei terribili le
parole finali del dio vivendo nel vostro
cerchio stretto ovvero la vostra terra
la fortuna vi passerà ovvero morirete ma
io nel mio mondo mi sento immortale e
freddo nella poesia c'è la vita i suoi
sogni ma anche le illusioni
altrettanto reali ci sono la piccolezza
la mutevolezza l'ipocrisia di cui è
fatto l'umano il limite non è di questo
mondo alla perfezione
eppure quella volta
quella volta per la prima volta tutti la
riconobbero tutti di fronte a tanta
bellezza si ritrovarono ad alzare lo
stesso numero quello della perfezione il
tabellone che non può superare i limiti
era programmato fino a 999 ma in realtà
quel voto era più alto sul tabellone
venne indicato il numero uno ma in
realtà era un 10 per la prima volta in
un'esibizione limbica rumena come e
nadia come ne la più grande ginnasta di
sempre almeno come me e mi ha il sado
viano scrittore divergenti la sua opera
più importante è balta gul tradotta in
italiano con il nome la scure lo dico
con orgoglio perché il suo piccolo paese
e il piccolo paese da cui provengo io e
questa è la casa che i miei genitori
stanno costruendo io vengo da policoro
provincia di matera
lì c'era un valore grandissimo che
nessuno sapeva sapeva come trovarlo a
volte oggetti di grande importanza che
erano lasciati a marcire in in in
depositi
eppure tante volte neanche cercati sotto
terra questo valore ce lo ha fatto
scoprire un grande archeologo oggi lì
c'è un bellissimo museo della magna
grecia e porta il suo nome di una da me
schiano rumeno come me gli orologi
rumeno come me ha giocato nel real
madrid barcellona e galatasaray e
persino in italia con il brescia
il re il comandante il maradona dei
carpazi
dopo aver fatto sognare i suoi i suoi
tifosi con le giocate migliori ha
iniziato a fare una cosa ancora più
grande
insegnare ne è nata così la accademia ag
un vivaio calcistico che forma i giovani
rumeni e poi nel 2009 ha formato una
squadra
questa squadra è poi approdata nel
massimo campionato romeno addirittura
l'anno scorso lo ha vinto questo
campionato
volete sapere quanto ha speso per
raggiungere questo sogno
qualche miliardo no 10 mila euro non ha
scommesso in soldi ma in speranza in
fiducia in futuro
a proposito di futuro romeno come me e
mihail kogalniceanu uomo politico del
xix secolo portò la romania verso un
grande sviluppo
era un uomo con lo sguardo sempre in
avanti
disse un giorno il mio paese e qualsiasi
posto nella terra in cui si parla rumeno
è proprio vero allora il nostro
orizzonte è il mondo
il concetto di nazione e prima culturale
che geografico e infatti io oggi qui
nella vostra nella vostra terra
mi sento romeno ma mi sento rumeno anche
grazie all'italia perché questi autori
non li conoscevo mi è stato chiesto qui
di scoprirli grazie alla vostra scuola e
allo stimolo di insegnanti che mi hanno
chiesto di andare a fondo alle mie
radici
perciò la mia idea è semplice quella di
una nuova sezione di ted per ragazzi
stranieri che prepari non
microconferenze sui grandi autori dei
loro paesi per in modo tale da non
rimanere soggetto passivo
dell'integrazione ma diventare
protagonisti dell'integrazione come è
successo a me in modo tale da non
limitarci solo a ricevere ma iniziare a
dare adesso guardate qui si intitola il
bacio un grande blocco di pietra che dà
forma a due persone che si baciano
gli occhi si fissano gli uni sugli altri
e le braccia si stringe in un abbraccio
amoroso
lo scultore elimina tutte le decorazioni
e vuole comunicarci una sola cosa la
felicità di un uomo e una donna che si
amano
l'autore di questa opera e constantin
brink's rumeno come me constantin brin
cluj grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]